bonjour jean marc sylvestre bonjour ma
jolie merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france alors les commerces
dits non essentiels les restaurants lé
théâtre vont pouvoir sortir de ce
déconfinement à partir du 19 mai mais
vont-ils y arriver parce qu'a priori et
les opérations ont l'air d'être un peu
compliqué jean marc voulait absolument
vous avez raison alors ils vont sortir
progressivement à partir du 19 mai bah
disons quand même que la majorité de
l'opinion publique est satisfait du
déconfinement les décideurs c'est à dire
les chefs d'entreprise croient que
l'économie va rebondir pourrait rebondir
dès cet été en théorie ils ont
totalement raison
il peut se passer d'ailleurs cette année
exactement ce qui s'est passé l'année
dernière on s'en souvient pas mais on va
on avait assisté l'année dernière à une
euphorie de consommation parce que tout
le monde là mais marc le monde espérait
aller au café au restaurant togo ne
voulait pas voyagé et s'amusait
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué la circulation dans paris
depuis lundi qu'on a supprimé la limite
des 10 km on a retrouvé les
embouteillages et on a l'impression que
c'est reparti mais je peux vous dire que
toutes les professions dont vous avez
parlé qui était éteint
les restos les commerces dans
l'essentiel et théâtre les campings
aussi les agences de voyages s'agite
actuellement et se prépare à accueillir
les clients dès le 19 mai dans des
conditions qui seront un peu compliqué
on pourra rouvrir avec un couvre-feu
repoussé à 21 heures et puis dans le
courant du mois de juin on sera
complètement des confinés sous certaines
conditions qui vont maintenir je vous le
disais délimitation assez draconiennes
et je crois que ce déconfinement sera
difficile à organiser à respecter et à
respecter ce calendrier peut-être à
cause des conditions draconiennes qui
sont imposées vous avez déjà pas mal
d'hôtels et de restaurants de magasins
de théâtre qui à paris notamment et dans
les grandes villes annonce d'ores et
déjà qu'ils ne pourront pas ouvrir leurs
portes avant le mois de septembre au
plus tôt alors donc ça laisse du temps
encore pour beaucoup pour débattre et
pour s'interroger sur les raisons de
tout ça
et pourquoi alors ce retard à l'allumage
selon vous alors il ya des raisons qui
sont très simples qui font que beaucoup
d'établissements n'ont pas intérêt à
ouvrir notamment dans les grandes villes
la première série c'est que les
touristes notamment ne seront pas là les
touristes chinois américains kidari tu
débarques par charters entiers sur paris
à partir du mois de juin à équiper vont
pas venir en france et et vous avez
beaucoup de commerces hôtels restaurants
civile du touriste étranger et notamment
du touriste chinois ou des touristes
américains les voyages ne seront pas
rétablis ou alors avec des rythmes des
restrictions qui vont les rendre très
rarissime ou très difficile la deuxième
série de raisons c'est qu'on va imposer
des jauges de fréquentation d'abord sur
les terrasses vous le verrez le 19
ensuite dans les salles de spectacles
tous les restaurants ils n'ont pas de
terrasse qu'à lire les deux tiers
pourront pas ouvrir le 19 sept
les hôtels qui avait déjà ouvert avant
sans restaurant sans doute pour filmer
leur ouverture mais beaucoup de palaces
ne vont pas ouvrir pour le théâtre c'est
la même chose tout va dépendre de la
jauge c'est à dire du nombre de
spectateurs qui sont autorisés à rentrer
dans la salle un restaurant une salle de
cinéma ou de théâtre et même un stade
d'ailleurs sportifs doivent être plein à
80 % en euros pour payer tous ces frais
la jauge sera inférieur à 80 ans sans
doute aux alentours de 50% de la
capacité à la peine d'être
polytechnicien et de faire des calculs
l'été a prêté ne vont pas rouvrir et
n'ont aucun intérêt à le faire
il perdait de l'argent il faut donc
négocier le maintien de leurs aides
publiques ce qui ajoute une troisième
raison c'est qu'il faut s'organiser
il faut s'organiser dans le commerce
d'un essentiel il faut reconstituer des
stocks d'été parce que actuellement on a
en magasin les stocks d'hiver qui n'ont
pas été payés faune donc les liquider il
faut acheter des nouveaux stocks
j'ajoute qu'il faut rattraper le
personnel qui va assez difficile
notamment dans la restauration parce
qu'il ne sait pas c'est un phénomène
intéressant dans la restauration
alors qu'ils avaient le chômage partiel
bien une partie du personnel a choisi
cette garantie pour abandonner sur
l'institut ancien métier et se former à
une nouvelle
tout ça fait que le défensivement mais
va demander beaucoup de temps ouais donc
difficile de trouver du personnel vous
avez raison
dans la restauration est ce que ça peut
compromettre la reprise économique de la
rentrée même alors écoutez globalement
va pas donner dans le pessimisme non
parce que le système économique
fonctionne il est trés résignant il a
montré qu'il était capable de faire
notamment grâce au digital pendant toute
une année les commerces et les
restaurants qui sont installés dans les
lieux de vacances vont fonctionner à peu
près normalement mais chavire plus que
normalement un les campings aussi on
sait déjà que les réservations font le
plein parce que même si les étrangers ne
viennent pas en france et 3 ne se
précipite pas dans les grands centres
touristiques que sont paris les châteaux
de la loire le mont saint michel ou
versailles eh bien les français eux ne
pourront pas partir à l'étranger
donc ils iront en bretagne dans le sud
ça fera donc beaucoup de clients et de
consommation en revanche il existe des
facteurs de risque qui peuvent retarder
cette cette reprise alors il ya
l'éventualité d'une quatrième vague qui
n'est pas à exclure
alors bon on n'en sait trop rien mais la
campagne de vaccination peut ne pas être
suffisante
même si elle se passe beaucoup mieux
aujourd'hui elle peut ne pas être
suffisante pour garantir cette immunité
collective à laquelle on aspire enfin on
peut aussi avoir un débat très
idéologique sur ce dont vous parliez
précédemment c'est à dire le passeport
sanitaires on voit bien ce qui se passe
il limitera l'utilisation ski c'est
ainsi que monsieur ce débat ce qui
serait utile serait une erreur parce que
pour protéger la liberté individuelle
on a ce trail des interdits finalement
ce qui n'est quand même pas propice au
redémarrage de l'économie la confiance
revenir que si et seulement si on
convient en gros trois ultimes la
vaccination
le testing et puis le passeport
sanitaire qui permettra de voyager pour
l'instant ça n'est pas encore la
stratégie officielle donc l'euphorie du
déconfinement n'est pas garanti si nous
avons encore 30 secondes
j'ajoute que les questions de l'emploi
vont être capitales
il ya des projets d'embauché ils sont
très importants pour les entreprises
notamment pour la rentrée
ces cétacés le pôle emploi vient de
sortir ces statistiques
ce matin on a environ 2 million à deux
millions cinq cent mille de projets
embauche de projets d'emploi avec un
problème le problème c'est de trouver
les candidats pour pouvoir satisfaire
ces temps ces emplois ces emplois qui
seront principalement d'ailleurs
concentrées dans l'ouest de la france
et ça c'est un phénomène assez nouveau
il va falloir gérer tout ça c'est pas
dit c'est pas fait c'est pas fait un mot
peut-être sur le le dépôt de bilan et à
la relance mais il ya aussi des
entreprises qui ont mis la clé sous la
porte notamment les salles de sport
c'est vrai que vous avez raison les
dépôts de bilan sont à craindre ces
dépôts de bilan je vais vous dire ils
dépendent essentiellement des décisions
qui seront prises au niveau de l'urssaf
parce que c'est l'urssaf la demande de
paiement des charges sociales qui
décidera du réglage ou de l'étalement de
ces dépôts de bilan si dépôt de bilan et
l'ia parce que finalement on s'aperçoit
que les entreprises ont beaucoup utilisé
le pge c'est à dire le prêt garanti par
l'état ce qui leur a donné de la
trésorerie et or on est plutôt optimiste
de ce point de vue là on craint un
certain nombre de défaillances
d'entreprises
mais ce sont des défaillances
d'entreprises qui toucheront des
entreprises qui était malade avant la
crise et toutes ces entreprises là et
bien l'heure de vérité va arriver mais
c'est vrai que ça risque de faire mal
merci beaucoup jean-marc pour toutes ces
précisions jean marc sylvestre l'édito
échos comme tous les mercredis